was founded by Satoshi Nakamoto now this
is actually just a pseudonym we don't
know whether Satoshi is one person or a
group of people and that's the beauty of
it the first smartest thing that Satoshi
Nakamoto did was creating Bitcoin the
second part that he or she or they would
ever did was disappearing in 2010. it's
so important that they disappeared Ross
Albrecht is the individual that created
the dark web on this dark web it's
called Silk Road they were trading in
Bitcoin and many different things and so
this individual is now serving several
life sentences in jail just because of
the capacity of what was created on this
website those at the top and the CIA
weren't okay with it they weren't okay
with this type of marketplace existing
then how on Earth are they going to be
okay with Bitcoin with Satoshi Nakamoto
creating an alternative monetary Network
which literally makes the essential bags
who by the way control the world
completely Obsolete and redundant the
second smartest thing the founder of
Bitcoin did was disappearing Satoshi
Nakamoto could be one two three four 100
people we don't even know so those are
the top don't even know who